[music playing]
JIM GREEN: We've been studying
the dust storms of Mars
for quite some time.
And there's a particular season
where some of the dust storms
can actually go global.
Not just regional, but global.
Dust storms on Mars can
be absolutely enormous.
They can be 20 to
30 kilometers high.
And in fact, the
dust can get charged.
And in the case of these
really tall dust storms,
lightning can strike.
[thunder]
ANDY WEIR: These
dust storms are huge.
They can cover
the entire planet.
And they can last for months.
They're visible from space.
Mars just kind of turns
into a hazy red ball.
And we can't see
surface, uh, features
anymore with our satellites.
The dust, it's not like sand.
It's like talcum powder.
It's-- it's very, very
microscopically small,
nasty dust particles.
And if they get into your lungs,
it's a human safety issue.
So, uh, you would
want to try to keep
it out as much as possible.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: There's
a lot of dust on Mars.
You know, we've
learned from our rovers
on Mars that they're constantly
getting covered in dust.
And one of the problems
with solar panels
is the dust would cover
them almost instantly
or they would simply
block out the sun
so much that they don't work.
If you got a dust storm that
lasted for a month on Mars,
and you were relying on solar
power, you'd be in big trouble.